one of the physiological scenarios
is probably very common in
you know has to do with diabetes I'm
diabetic and my great-grandfather was
diabetic his daughter like grandmother
was diabetic five of her six sons were
diabetic one of whom was my father
so you see a very genetic disease here
okay that's in in my case type to date
diabetic so you know adult onset
so my cells are insulin resistant so if
I eat a meal that has carbohydrate or
fat in it like pancreas is probably
responding and I probably like my beta
cells in my Cantonese are probably ok
but the insulin just isn't able by
producing insulin and but the insulin
just isn't able to signal my cells to be
able to take up the glucose as a
consequence I'm somewhat in a technical
state of starvation mic like egde and
reserves are therefore smaller than
yours and I can tell this in times for
example when I was first became diabetic
I loved mountain climbing and hiking and
so on and I that I would go out and I'd
be totally exhausted for the first ten
minutes or so and that's because I have
very small glycogen reserves what I had
to do is this metabolic switch over to
booting up oxidative metabolism of fats
that all had to be turned on and it's
hard it's a hard transition but once it
got going as long as I stay aerobic in
other words I don't go so fast that I go
anaerobic I can climb forever because if
I stay aerobic I've got plenty of fat
reserves in fact it's probably a good
thing
that I'm burning them so I'm just a
little bit different
I'd like to teach this
seven in part because I was probably not
that many kids in the class you know 100
hundred and thirty or so students would
be diabetic but it's about six to eight
percent of the population in the United
States right now and so you know
everybody knows someone is diabetic or
maybe your parents are and you know what
are the risk factors so we teach that